so we know a lot of afghan refugees are
coming here how many exactly where are
they going how are they being processed
when they get here we have answers to
some of those questions tonight here's
what we've learned
from government
sources dallas airport in right outside
washington is a main welcoming site for
flights landing at all hours of the day
filled with afghan refugees as of this
morning just under 3
700
men from afghanistan have been processed
at dulles one recent flight landed there
with nearly 200 evacuees homeland
security officials are currently
discussing opening similar sites at
other airports around the country dhs
has also been also been soliciting
volunteers to staff its processing
centers overseas there are currently
three of those that are vetting refugees
in bahrain qatar and germany the
administration is planning to open four
other overseas processing sites dhs's
goal it says is to process 10 000
refugees every day at many of these
overseas location so we reached out to
dhs for comment on friday a spokesman
there said that they are quote working
around the clock to ensure individuals
are screened against u.s government
databases prior to arriving in the us
and upon arrival these are the people
who had no idea the taliban were going
to take kabul in a weekend what will
happen
well their attitudes a lot of good
people but are very different from those
of most americans
a new poll by pew found that 99 of
afghan muslims support for example
enacting sharia law
so many republicans in congress have no
problem with this at all in fact some of
those want us to evacuate afghans from
kabul before we get all americans
citizens out of the country one of those
republicans not surprisingly is ben
sasse of nebraska the single guiltiest
white man in america
sas said over the weekend we need to
take in as many refugees as possible
because america has given its word he
didn't say to whom hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else